[موسيقى]
يقال انه تم انشاءها من اجل حمايه اخر ما
تبقى من سلاله تيس الجبل الحديقه الوطنيه
لافنوز
جنوب شرق فرنسا
[موسيقى]
وكذلك الحيوانات التي تختبئ فيها
يقترح على الزوار طريقه خاصه لاكتشاف
المكان
كلما كانت تسلق اكثر حده نرفع كعوبنا اكثر
لنكون قادرين على ننشوب مخالبانه مثل
القطط
هذه العائله القادمه من ليون طلقت قليلا
صخب الحياه للارتماء بين احضان الامكنه
الواسعه واقتفاء اثر الحيوانات
جبلي
بعد ساعتين من التجوال سياتي صبرهم ثماره
الان
انا راسه الان انه ابيض
انه واقف على رجليه
الحيوان بصوره مختلفه
[موسيقى]
بوضوح رايناه من جانبه ايضا وشاهدنا قرونه
لابد من المشي كثيرا وبذل مجهود كبير كي
نستمتع في هذه الحديقه الناصعه البياض لا
يقتصر الامر على رؤيه الضباء فقط ليس
بعيدا من هنا يخيل الينا لوهله اننا نستمع
الى عوائد الذئاب
[موسيقى]
انها كلاب حمى ذهب لقد اراد الباحثون عن
الذهب بكلابا مقاومه مثل سلاله الهسكي
سيري لكن سريع اكثر لان الذي يصل اولا هو
اول من ياخذ ذلك الذهب لهذا كان الامر
شبيها بالمنافسه
الاستكشافيه بالنسبه لهؤلاء السياح وسط
اشجار الصنوبر ساعتان من المتعه التي ستظل
راسخه في الذاكره
هذه الاماكن كلها مخصصه للراعي في الصيف
نجل ابقرا هنا المزرعه التي ترونها هناك
هي للرعي لا يوجد فيها احد في فصل الشتاء
لكن في الصيف ياتي اليها الراعي مع ابقاره
[موسيقى]
ا كل ما لديها من خبره في مجال التزلج
بقياده الكلى
رائع هل فهمت الان بحبك يا ابله وانتم هل
كل شيء على ما يرام
بشكل جيد لكن ماذا عن الاخرين يا ترى
[تصفيق]
نستخدم فيه جميع اعضاء جسمنا لكن الامر
ممتعا حقا
اكثر
اجل يكفي فقط قطعه 15 سنتيمترا من سمك هذا
الجليل
تتحل بها هذه المراه التي رفعت التحدي
عاليا
بدله ثقيله بسمك سبعه ملمترات تجعل
حركاتها بطيئه لكن الامر يتطلب ذلك
مجنون مجنون
هذا في البدايه بمعنى
اهداني زوجي هذه الرحله بمناسبه عيد
الميلاد
وجدت نفسي في قلبي هذه المغامره دون
الاستعداد لها نفسيا
لاول مره
عشرون دقيقه وستدرجه واحده فوق الصفر
هل انت بخير
عالم غريب نكتشفه عن قرب فضاء مغلق تماما
من كل الجهات تحت سقف من جديد لا يوجد اي
مخرج تقريبا حتى بالنسبه لفقاعه الهواء
الصغيره
اختبار للجسد كمال الروح
في هذه المياه الجليديه
لا تيتهم بقى
وسط الجليدي
امر ممتع حقا انه اكثر من رائع
او تزلجا او استمتاعا بالحياه البريه
مرتفعه لافانواز تضمن لكم انقطاعا تاما عن
صاحب المدينه وضجيج الحياه اليوميه